hello everyone welcome to part two of
this I shouldn't play the people we
actually had some technical difficulties
and we're coming back to do this again
and it's really sad Toni everybody
missed it I just beat Magnus Carlsen you
know we played on a private server so
you can't find the game anywhere but but
yeah for real yeah absolutely one game
those five rating points have bumped us
over to or over mm so thumbs up thumbs
up alright so we're gonna play some more
how about this person here 68 alright
we're at 2,000 to 1 and we need to stay
above 2000 so you can only lose at one
point I'm not gonna lose one point
awesome I love it
awesome what did you play that you play
the English no this is a d4 this is
called the Banco gambit now at this
point it's known to not be so great for
black but when I play it it's really not
good for black okay alright well you
heard it Yamato let's see what you got
yeah hey Carl Nakamura has a game that
went like this from a US Championship
one time and I think it has a different
name to at this point like after you've
played a six and they take on e6 you
take back with the F pawn it's called no
no maybe one of our listeners out there
knows what it's called but who know only
have nine people when watching right now
thank you nine people all nine of you
what do you tell ya we need you guys
basically start to start this over again
all right so yeah well oh we have you
loving people now well those of you who
are joining us thank you for coming back
we have some issues we have it hopefully
we have it resolved permanently but with
technology nowadays probably not you
know with a new Terminator movie coming
out got my Terminator is the reason our
stream window you never know man sarnax
works with a girl
Scotty who's Skynet sky Manette my mom I
be up and running you know is it Arnold
Schwarzenegger still he's in the movie
but he's like super old so like how you
gonna play that like it's true thinks I
thought you're gonna take in and bring
you're not another night the other night
no I got to worry about this e6 pawn cuz
he's gonna play like a Knight to g5 if
his Queens on e4 he's hitting the pawn
so I think I'm gonna just your typical
Banco stuff and put everything on the
queenside
although at this point I'm not sure in
your typical Banco because I'm not
really familiar with these lines where
I've got an open F file maybe I should
be attacking on the Kings side but we'll
just play some chess and see what
happens right Yamato I mean I really
thought you open up a file just to have
that rook there but I did yeah alright
viewers let us know in the chat of what
your leech has name is and we will play
you put you on a listen play you
hopefully we should have enough time to
play some more people 17 alright if you
worship keeps going up I love it love it
so tea rich let me let me ask you this
Danny Danny was talking about this
before the show started and I want to
see what your view on this is genetic
engineering oh you know how the people
yeah yeah you know how nowadays um I'm
like ah China has successfully
genetically engineered some some kids
yeah for sure if you let okay so let's
say it's been FDA approved like blah
blah gone through all the tests and it's
safe 100 let's say like 99 percent safe
is that something you what you would do
well okay so a few things first of all I
think it would depend upon what you're
trying to genetically modify in a and a
kid or something you know if it is to
prevent disease or illness or or
something like that
sure I could see a good argument for it
if it's more like you know designer
babies and making sure that you've got a
kid that has the right hair color or
something like that yeah not not so much
obviously so it's really more of a
nuanced conversation than that
but you know if it were something where
I knew that my kid had a gene for for
breast cancer and changing that gene
would get rid of the the chance of
breast cancer a greatly reduce it sure
why not I think that's I think that
makes good sense I think the argument is
like once you start going down doesn't
matter like even if it's for curing
disease or just to make someone better
than they already are
once you do one of those things the
others gonna come along right with it
sure slippery slope argument
you know like for all of you Star Trek
fans out there you know like Conn
genetic engineer captain it was like to
his tire low ship kind of stuff stuff
like that like you're like when you
start competition like your parents are
competitions who's better who can you
know who can have the better better
grades and all that what better life
blah blah blah I think what if do you
think it will inexorably lead to that I
mean do you think if soon as we start
genetically engineering kids it's gonna
be we make a super race of brilliant
children and I think if there are no
rules implemented to stop that it will
eventually lead lead to that I think
they agree it would need some oversight
yeah for sure like I'll give you give
you an example so I was I grew up in
China right and you know what grant cram
schools are so like in addition to
regular school key there is cram schools
in which all you go go there just to do
like do more work and learn about the
currents that you're learning in school
so it's like you're re rebuilding your
kind of basically so like and the thing
is if one kid goes then every other kid
has to go because they're gonna fall
fall behind if they don't you know so
that that's the that's the kind of
conundrum like if you if one party if
one kid is Jamaican engineer to be
better than everybody else and everybody
else is gonna eventually come along to
that okay you don't know you don't want
to fall behind it's true it's true you
know
so there you go Danny Machuca the answer
is yes
all right so Tony what do I do here now
do I play wait Zach wait I think I
played 95 here so I'm trying to make
this bishop be as bad as I can so I want
to remove they have three night you know
cuz right now my e4 Knight and my rook
both attack the bishop and if you
noticed well before the knight was here
the bishop had no good squares so he
just retreats it I agree take it yeah
I've got I hate to get rid of my e4
Knight though it's such a beautiful
square
let's do like this
play like a crazy person
so I've got nice c3 ideas at some point
maybe also this night this rook attack
f2 is he getting rid of that bishop I
know he's doing a good job of guarding
everything you ever do think about
something like rook takes at f2 and then
try to drive it yeah maybe so if I play
Knight takes rook takes would you take
that I take the F 3 9 and said Knight
takes pawn takes yeah again I don't know
that I'd get a whole lot here Batman
beat begins wants to play Knight of
Amarok once that's the guy that I wanted
to play you wanted to see you play
didn't Enzo okay a night of Amarok night
of amrok you're up next night of amrok
all right and then there's Mike perky
sure for Michael Riggins okay we'll get
to you we'll try to get to you should I
get to you no promises cuz you never
know there could be some more technical
difficulties hey 53 people watching now
yeah it went from like almost up 100
then we had to stop to zero no it came
back to 50 something love it let's see
you are down on time you are down in
material oh me oh no you're not sorry
night I don't know this is a rook and
that's a bishop sorry sorry I probably
didn't play this as precisely as I could
have but that's all these seconds I
think I'm gonna do okay with this just
5-0 where's this I don't know what I'm
playing 500 so I gotta play quick got it
alright I'm gonna pay attention there
you go there you go
boom yeah I think it's pretty pretty
good I think this is a war you can do a
3/32 it's a way for you yeah for sure
cuz this bishop hang to is the problem
yep I want to keep it about to the up
he's in trouble too oh no oh yeah motto
come on Yamato no yeah you're you're
done on time and material now what you
gonna do
should played faster is this a lag going
on oh no check
do a little check for risky well I'm
gonna take that Bishop with check next
yeah I had to take the rook first cuz if
I play rook takes baby as king f2 yeah
he's got to play like h3 or something
yeah oh just win it this stupid night
okay if I played rookie wani as night c2
you're still defending so I think that I
should've done that the move before but
maybe not that's cool you're up on time
look at that alright Yamato hands good
nice try nice try nice try
thank you for the game alright who's my
opponent now night of Amarok if he's
there there he is
five five high five watts amrok we
talked about this five zero man yeah
five five gonna be kind of long so I
might resign if safer right well we'll
see if we can play the names of which so
knight c6 and d5 huh like you say sure
well I guess I have to take pawns back
right what's he gonna do tacky Holly
Knight c3 Knight f3 c4
I'm gonna be greedy and I'm gonna take
this d4 pawn maybe green is good
greed is good it's one of the sins that
uh get you a lot in life I just watched
the movie se7en again it was on TV the
other day I haven't seen it in years and
years really good talk about since 90s
made yeah it's got a real really old
dun dun dun let's see here
gang sigue appreciate your viewership I
love it morally is better I don't think
it should be playing God I feel like all
surgeons play God really I it's cousin
all the movie movies out there about
like surgeons being but does your
mechanic play God I mean he fixes your
break so you don't crash and die you're
you're referring to fixing fixing a
inanimate object as opposed to like
making somebody live again so uh well I
don't know I it's tricky sure playing
God may be yes but the whole point is
we're trying to take care of each other
so doctors come into it with a mindset
of hey let's make let's make people
healthy let's make the world a better
place
it's not like they come into with this
you know evil grin and the twisting of
the moustache man there are so many
movies out there where it's just like
the plot is basically you're a surgeon
you have two people you can save but you
can only have time to save one what do
you do thank God right there
that's like the old trolley problem
right you have five people so there's
train tracks that split there are five
people that are working on the tracks on
one side and only one person working on
the tracks on the other you have the
ability right now the trains gonna going
to go and hit the five people and kill
all of them you have the ability to flip
a switch and you'll save those five
people's lives but you'll be condemning
the one person on the other side of the
track still do you play God do you pull
the switch and kill what your decision
has led one person to die but you've
saved five that that's exactly my point
like you you made the choice you like
you're playing God you make the choice
for one person to die even though it's
good for the better the whole well I
you made that choice all right seven
from 1995 thank you very much
MSP appreciate the fact more Mulroy to
288 can we play we'll try to get to you
no promises some people call me a mole
Royce of course science mostly is good
you can't pull the lever
you can't pull the little lever so
you're when you say you can't pull the
lever Michael Perkins there you talking
about like the situation with the Train
like you can save say five you have to
kill one in that case I think
philosophically you should write save
save the majority no no no let's say
okay if I were the one that's gonna die
I was still I mean you I would still do
it it's bet it's best for the majority
let's make it a little bit more nuanced
though what if it was five strangers and
the one person is your best friend or
your mom you know I mean okay - shame
shame I gotta make it so hard but really
I think at that point though the
question is no longer you know what it's
the moral decision the question is how
likely are you to make the the most
moral decision compared to making the
decision that benefits you the most
it's tough to say I I think if I just
save like my my sister as opposed to
like ten strangers the ten strangers can
basically die that's that's that's how
my view is now shoot as I say Knight
takes d4 Bishop takes d4 Castle
queenside and I was gonna win a bishop
but he's got Bishop takes g7 at the end
of all that
all right why are we at 6:16 2000
because 5 5 says grant I'm controlling
yes yeah dang it's nighttime a rock you
you made his play it time when we were
not 2000 anymore haha that's ok will
gain some reading points here to
hopefully
both have bishop beers that's pretty
good he still have to 250 let's Wow jail
yeah okay your your night on gee it's
not doing anything what do you get that
sucker out of there and I was busy
getting the rest of their suckers out of
there you know come on give me a break
his all his minor pieces are active oh
I'm half a move behind he so he has to
react to the fact that I'm hitting his
Bishop now and so whenever he reacts to
that I can develop my piece and then
again you know right say you're gonna
try that trade that Y squared Bishop off
so you can get get that pond yeah maybe
yeah if he plays like Bishop e2 I can
just take it and I can play Knight takes
on c4 let me get Castle queenside maybe
two it's interesting magnus carlsen said
something you heard of that guy he's
pretty good at chess I I think I heard
of that name once or twice he said
something about how if you're what was
it if you're one move away from castling
you're fine if you're two moves away
from castling it's questionable and if
you're three moves away from castling
you're much worse you know and I don't
think that means like in every single
position but especially whenever you're
developing tit-for-tat with your
opponent I develop a piece you develop a
piece I get something out of the way you
get something out of the way I think
that's more what he's referring to so
okay so we got to move our Bishop yep do
it
yeah I want everything developed I want
to play Knight f6 and rook HD e8 all at
the same time and there's got to be some
kind of a discovered threat and you know
Knight takes pawn or Bishop takes pawn
or maybe even like rook takes this
Knight at that point I wonder if he's
gonna try to yes I guess you can play
Bishop ii ii ii and castle maybe
chirping Castle queenside developed a
bishop he can play he's not gonna cast
out Queen side let's face facts there
why not it's horrible horrible okay you
can just play oh he didn't have such
poise you know what 9m rock here we go
here we go well you do we're gonna do a
little Bishop takes at Bishop takes c3
get that double upon in front of the
King you wanna do that no I think I'm
gonna finish developing my pieces
develop oh yeah I love keeping the both
bishops you know the two bishops here so
even though these pawns would be weak
you know I don't have a whole lot of
stuff they can easily get over there to
attack all those weak pawns especially
with his King being over there the King
can defend the pawns in fact going back
to Magnus again there were a couple of
times where he's recently played a game
like this where you know he gets a
busted-up queenside pawn structure like
pawns on a to c3 that kind of thing and
he's still castles Queen side it's
[Music]
now you're your knight on f3 is f6 is
not great okay I'm gonna do it I knew it
uh I'm gonna pause up there we go in it
the only risk of the knight on c5 cuz
you're right that knight on f6 wasn't
doing a whole lot I didn't want to give
away d5 to his Knight so I traded his
night off first and now I'm gonna
reroute this guy to c5 you know one of
the best squares for for a minor piece
like this or a knight look at this guy
cheeky cheeky move cheeky move let's see
here yes I were to say I'd rather save
10 strangers haha eat a latarian
wouldn't argue that more people survive
the better okay alright we get an inter
latarian argument you get it yep yep and
it's by a person with the name revenge
okay cool so I'm a little worried about
this nut on a 7 because at some point I
think I get to play c5 and then this
Knights not defended anymore are you
gonna play c5 Knight next move oh you
can't
so if I start with C 6 and then C 5 yeah
I think he's gonna do a little rook
Sacko ruski rook DD 6 maybe so rook D 6
I think you just drop your rook because
I can play King C 7
you don't have Bishop c5 oh yeah pawn c5
aha that's cute root d6 King c7 pawn c5
then I can come back King b8 because by
playing c5 you've broken the
communication between your Bishop and
your knife that's cute
all right we're gonna block it block it
let's do it
so I expected f4 Hammurabi's just block
to you and you only have 25 seconds dude
you are just going down right now
yeah I think pawn dad for was a better
try this way I think you're just
dropping a piece well you're doing good
right now
man night not a mirage uses getting
checked everywhere always check your
cookie shhh and then what they say we
want that piece we want that piece
I think it has to play Bishop d1 not
which to
check in a three
but you just get rid of that bishop it
was annoying
I don't understand Danny just Oh cuz the
bishop covers a four okay so if we get
the chance to do it again
Danny Danny my shoe is putting out a
great mate you know that's right we
still got to meet anyway oh we still got
it we still do not harm Rock you're
going down man thanks for the game I'm
gonna pre give you the one of these
night nice try nice try good job all
right we're gonna be a raw maurois okay
here we go
was as I learned to play chess moving
your knight to files like H and a was
for forbidden okay all right nowadays I
see a lot more puzzles where it counts
as a good solution without any real
explanation any thoughts on that
sure yeah so when he learned this
gentleman learned how to play chess
going putting a night on the a where
h-file was work was forbidden for him
but now he sees a lot of puzzles where
like that's actually a solution to a
puzzle yeah so that's the thing about
puzzles right is there oh my god I like
do something let me figure out where my
pieces go for a second I know I don't
know any French theory and somehow I got
tricked into playing an advanced French
here I mean that's the whole point of
puzzles though right is that it's gonna
be something weird and quirky you know
one of the things that I've been what
I've witnessed people who are good at
solving puzzles do is they'll say you
know they'll look at the position
overall there will be some complex of
pieces doing something interesting you
know tactically interacting with each
other and then there will be a random
pawn you know pawn on a - that looks
like it has nothing to do with anything
it's not part of the position it doesn't
really go it doesn't make sense but that
pawn it turns out will end up being you
know the interesting piece the one
that's important it has some some
critical little thing where you get to
the end of all of this tactical sequence
and then you complete this
pawn move so yeah the people I know that
are better than me at solving puzzles
that's one of the things they do is they
say look for that little weird thing
about the position the thing that
doesn't make any sense and that's
probably going to be the the important
factor so we have a lot of there's a lot
of grandmasters and we'll just say at a
certain level and once you get to a
certain level the way you get better is
just to be tactically that better
working on tactics truly basically and
consistent you know that's oh absolutely
the important part there is being
consistent - you have to be accurate
every single movie no mistakes no like I
almost played Bishop b5 check but it
allowed knight c6 and then I just drop a
piece so you have to make sure that like
not only do you find those really cool
dazzling flashy moves whenever they come
about but that you consistently find
good moves what's what's wrong what's
wrong whoops okay you caught me
it's spend too much time chit-chatting
thank you for the game all right let's
do it again might so Micah / / / Keys
Ben and then Batman BBB again still
those who has been on challenges for a
while Batman Batman you're on man you're
on Oh we've played Batman a lot dude
look at this we have a ten and a half
four and a half scores actually he
challenges to like every time that we
had to do this alright uh-oh
PSG soccer rook says play me I will
crush you probably I'm weak
so PSU sorry I remember you from
previous sections we've had this are you
are you the PHP SG soccer fan from from
the France is that you
well we'll see yeah well we'll put you
on the list and see how you do 2008 or
2003 woo woo
basically the same rating I want some
points some points okay so what am I
supposed to do against this line when
well win that's a good idea
you haven't play me yet my username is
tap area one two three all right we'll
try to get to you no promises
who's that
how tall Perry one two three
all right tell Perry we'll give it a
shot
haha top areas like if you don't want to
lose too badly then don't play me dang
all this trash hog oh I don't know if
that yeah I don't know if you're trying
like reverse psychology to where we
actually wanted to play you then but
I'll show you how bad oh do you want to
accept a 1-1 minute game 1-0 I'll play
one really okay alright well I'm I'm
terrible at bullet so this one I
probably will lose but uh try an
Australian challenges a10 see if we'll
see where you actually take it or not I
feel like a lot of challenges are either
accepted or declined by the way we feel
that second it's true so well we'll see
who we actually hit who actually feel
playing you once we get to that point
it's true so can you guys name the
famous players that have played the
Bangko gambit there's obviously pal
Benko who it's named after recently
passed away he's an American Grandmaster
you know you're asking our viewers that
they can I'm gonna say like not many of
you actually know Danny this is not for
you this is for our viewers Danny's
trying to Danny in the back trying to
y'all some ain't answers for us so that
was a hit Magnus Carlsen
that's one yes there's another world
champion I'm thinking of though - let's
see if Danny can get this one I don't
think he can
no it's not not mikkel tall thanks for
the live show you guys thumbs up thumbs
out to you Loreena thumbs up to you I'll
give you a hint it was not the garry
kasparov lineage of world champions it
was the feat a world champions it was
during that during that phase from the
the 90s until 2000 when they had the
reunification match where Garry Kasparov
was the classical world champion and
then feed a had a separate World
Championship cycle and so like Kasparov
he ended up playing kramnik in 2000 and
that's what were unified the titles
kramnik held the feed a world
championship title Kasparov held be
classical world championship title and
in Kasparov as we know lost that match
and retired from chess a few years later
but now it was one of those feed a world
champions in that interim period who's a
unknown Banco gambit player so we have
some answers from an audience tall we
are I said not tall Spassky that's a
little spaciest a little Spassky was
before Castro somebody more controls
Carlson's sometimes yet we said Carlson
already so there's one more person is he
a Russian player is that what you're
talking about
Oh Ukrainian Ukrainian okay Ukrainian
GM's guys y'all are out yell it out
we're gonna move my queen somewhere so
if we all give up I will give you the
answer yeah I'll give you one more
really close to applause Bulgarian
though I'll give one more hint he played
the person I'm thinking of played an
exhibition match at the Chess Club it
was our first international event that
we held at the club and his opponent was
Hikaru Nakamura at the time it's not a
bad trick not even shocked what other
Ukrainian players do you guys know
Ukrainian Ukrainian some guy just said
don't know Oh corabeth Carl Baugh is a
great guest he's a good player too but
no it was actually Ruslan ponomaryov
slump I was just googling this man
[Music]
so ponomaryov used to be uh I think you
still a 2700 grandmaster but he used to
be way up there let me say he was in the
top you know 10 15 in the world oh I
have a problem here I'm gonna move my
Bishop because it's attacked Batman
Begins company's gonna play f4 nobody's
not okay okay we're okay we're okay
let's just everybody calm down family
we're okay but good job good job
well no it's still complicated I'm not
sure that he's winning here no for
example I'm threatening his rook to my
stuff I'm skimming here him a prop house
because they know all the shows we had
that's not don't get forward then you
got forwards well yeah but I forked back
I'm not for it really kind of so I'm
threatening Bishop takes d4 I'm also
threatening to remove the defender of
this Knight and I'm also threatening to
take this rook
so he took him to take back now if I
take here he takes my rook right and
then you take a dead man
yeah seems fair and if I play Knight
takes rook I don't know what's happening
how you take his bid Bishop I'll just
take this guy this one looks important
get rid of that dish now that Bishop was
a monster and an important resource to
if he plays Bishop f1 I had a Queen
takes Knight yeah oh gosh key all right
all right
oh you want palm grabbing there yeah so
now do I take this bishop or do I try to
save my knight if I try to save my
nightie as bishop f-1 save tonight maybe
no I think I'm attacking we're attacking
we're basically saying screw you we're
attacking you
Braunstein let's see here yeah can I
somehow share the screenshot of the
puzzle I was talking about I really like
the explanation okay sure
share with us Bronstein once said we are
living in an era that the beauty of a
chess game is in the analysis and not in
the plate moves in what era do you guys
think we are living in now okay ready to
go
so Bronstein once said we are living in
an era that the beauty of chess game is
in the analysis and not in the plate
moves in what era do you guys think we
are living in now oh I mean definitely
computers right now it's the era of
computers it's we're seeing not just
players starting to play more like the
computers you know either defending
difficult positions or or or playing
positions that at first glance don't
look so great but the computer finds
these hidden resources
Batman Begins that was cheeky it was but
yeah I think that's really what it is
it's computers are teaching us how to
play better how to find hidden you know
resources maybe that we wouldn't have
found before I think the first real
player he's gonna do that's the one he's
gonna block it yeah and then I win the
rug is done I love it
you just got tactic Batman Begins tactic
so is this a fork or a skewer or an
x-ray or a pin I don't know the words
gonna call that winning all right thank
you for the game Batman much fun okay
let's play this one out game oh yes you
sucker you were out 2500 psg soccer he
he acted challenges all the time too I
mean Danny is there a way this guy can
share a screenshot with us
do what don't email if you want to give
us a screenshot ee mail it to us
info as st. Louis Chess Club org Danny
was saying to you email to my to my
email address let's not do that info as
saying let's just help that work can I
access info yes III I cannot but I know
people that can't so I know a guy I know
a guy for example if this guy sending
right next when you can I'm slow
Jonathan's runs the club man in the
manager aka Dragonslayer he can do that
as well so we'll probably ask him
mr. Siberia said good game Daniel ROA
Berger gave you a hand clap thank you
thank you it was fun
Phe soccer
oh is this was what what time control
was this bullet Oh me your book yeah she
you playing bullet huh okay dang dang oh
no ok lost a piece that's ok that's
alright ok
life happens you know
pushing baby
all right everything's under control
right and I expect Knight c3
well basically after you lost that piece
I was like I'm not gonna watch any
working I lose sorry if I don't have any
confidence to you that's just life oh I
ran out of time
I'm so slow I started thinking about the
position again man yeah three seconds
all right maybe one or two more games
and then we gotta get out of here
I'll do a bullet game one more bullet
and then I'll play another real game and
then we'll wrap it up so we're playing
vit are you are you playing bullet
because you lost that last game and I'm
on till 1867
that's our bullet rating yep it's higher
than I thought it was gonna be I thought
anyway lower cuz we generally don't
don't play bullet
[Music]
oh so we're my cover yeah
we're being told that my comers the only
one to actually place bullet nobody else
actually does so that's actually pretty
if that's all him that's pretty
impressive
I figure some young kids you know some
teenagers like Nick riscos like I'll
play bollocks I'm fast because young
people live their life quarter mile at a
time all the time I've been watching a
lot of clearly this guy looks like Eric
Rosen's dad oh look at that I didn't
know about that that's cool okay okay
that's a make sure he does his homework
yeah I don't know what I just did I
spent like 30 seconds calculating a
moving bullet so that's just ridiculous
oh just do not natural moves man natural
moves you like a nice Gary just yeah so
bad
find it find it
Oh Jason play there I like it
oh come on
down on your downtime bit down on time
bit oops
doesn't matter yeah five seconds go go
go yeah cream oh there you go
win on time waiting on time yeah
pre-emptive hand vet good try
it's right oh good try just give it up
man good try oh you can do me oh good
job Wow alright sorry stupid nicknames
only rated game baby games only barbar
Tex sure five artex one more one more
alright Bartek where are you from Bartek
looks like he plays everything on Leech
s yeah wait we we see him all the time
on the show so he's a regular all right
I just started playing this two nights
stuff in the complaint is really bad
line it's terrible don't ever play this
for real age six is probably just
winning but I started playing this in
three Oh mostly cuz it's really tricky
if they just play like e6000 for tricks
not really correct okay uhare hurt at
bar tacks were playing for tricks
playing for tricks
17 look I got all my pieces developed
except this stupid guy in the stupid one
I mean you usually wouldn't they just uh
oh I thought you just I thought there
was just meant take your knight on h3
that's usually what they do yeah but
they won't play Bishop g4 first
typically
yeah get rid of that pin okay where's
that pen would you do it would you cat
kind of Castle queenside [ __ ] oh there
we go we pushed D forward
yeah I think I'm gonna go for it and
we're gonna pawn pawn storm you bar Tex
pawn storm is coming but first get our
own King to safety right
DNA won't worry about keen safety I
thought you were reckless okay
sometimes what's interesting is if he
plays a five maybe I don't Castle
queenside because you know the the
nonsense coming okay we're going back to
our young younger days reckless that's
right push push forward push forward
yeah I was a little too worried about
the Queen side my bishop was gonna come
under fire yeah he was gonna pump on
pushy too so right good choice choice
Danny would sugar and the bag is
laughing at us cuz apparently we're not
follow and then Isaac's is following
suit he is also laughing at us yeah but
the difference is Danny's like you know
a 2,200 player and Isaac let's just say
he's not
day-day me too
all right can I get an F 4 F 5 somehow
maybe we first like would push really I
want maybe to bring this Bishop back or
something at some point I haven't
decided exactly what's happening yet
push that go ahead and push it go and
push it okay always play up three and
then he's gonna think he's gonna play
[ __ ] in d5 and then I can play my
Bishop c2 idea this is probably good it
you know I've got my bishop on a I think
more attacking day are you gonna push up
on c4 and win the bishop yeah don't be
crazy we can still do it
see this is what I mean but you have to
be consistent you know you have to find
C for every single time now like me
where you find it the next move because
somebody told you about it alright my
tanks we're officially up on Monte Rio
see I'm just defending my night that's
all
I have no threats at all check check
coming up here
all right so we start with check you
know purple your night I'm gonna play 96
no no that's Intermezzo that's good the
idea well the idea is that if he plays
Queen e7 then I'm gonna just made him
like this but if he plays Queen out
there maybe I take on g7 with something
well obviously the Queen right Bishop
takes well if I play Queen takes King e7
then what
and I think I just have to play king
upright Hoss well I mean you're a bit
vicious protecting gt3 in the worry
about that is that what you worried
about no I'm more worried about these
rooks so like for example if I play
Queen takes and he plays King e7 and I
play King g2 then he has rook g8 and my
Queen's trapped but if I play a bishop
chat Bishop takes then the bishop helps
cover some of these squares back here
for me so I think this is probably the
better way to go
I thought you were gonna leave your
Bishop on ie5 just so you can bring your
knight to these safes oh that would have
been good too but I think he has takes
it just a sack the exchange there this
is pretty good though take all your
pawns and then I'll worry about what
happens you managed to win by 0.1 second
yes you did great job great job
I thought you weren't - I thought you
were down everyone I'm oh I'm so stupid
dude that's why that's why Bartek your
bishop was there to protect that square
do I resign or can I even play anything
here let me think
1 2 3 6 I think you could put
potentially night like Knight b6 forward
it doesn't really do anything though
yeah what's not resigned though Oh am I
just gonna get made it though that's
what's happening actually I'm not even
losing my queen if I play King backe as
Queen g3 if I play King bagginess Queen
Age 3
okay all right thank you very much
Stavros Erick good seeing you too
good thank you for joining us finest
actor bishop on it okay five minutes ago
whatever sure again okay let's play one
more we can't lose sorry guys no casual
games only rated right now you know
better know better
let's see we're ready please stupid
nickname we played did we play master
tomato yet and may have not all right
we'll play this guy my master tomato
tonight 1999 we got one point I offer a
draw right now get that one honey
you guys are probably too young to
remember but I think it was
dan quayle I think it was dan quayle he
was vice president for George Bush the
first one he had a little campaign snafu
where there was something where they
were calling him an idiot because they
did not a spell tomato because he put an
e on the end of it and that back then
that could ruin your political career
people thought you were dumb because you
put an e on the end of the word tomato
now you can do just about anything and
still be a politic literally just about
anything you're right
borrows syrup bar Soros said I'm from
Poland good game
thank you yes thanks let's see Santa
mistake yes that was a sad mistake how
many hours of instruction are we doing
in the classroom this these days like
per week per week I want to say roughly
around like 275 275 hours hours permits
per week and st. Louis pools so that's
awesome I know we've got a big a big
team of instructors they go out you know
we typically look for people that have
some kind of a background in education
either they were classroom teachers or
have been a tutor or something like that
so we look for folks like that and then
bring him in a little bit of chest
knowledge is required to begin with but
really we can work on that part correct
for all those of you who are actually we
actually know anything about scholastic
chests you know that majority of them I
was like almost 9% are all beginner
chests so our goal is really just to
spread chess as much as we can
except your select chess program except
for the select chess program yes our
views actually know a lot about this
I've been talking about this almost
every time but so we gather some of the
top top rate rated kids in st. Louis -
with the goal of getting them to a title
either hopefully GM at the very least nm
I am all that stuff so it's actually
taught by grandmaster we're version of
Kobe in who has is living in st. Louis
and he actually just finished his
tournament and I oh man I think he was
squirrel where was his score like it was
like he scores six points maybe gotta
have someone I believe you so he did he
didn't think he was I think he did
pretty good he's coming back today
actually he'll be so he will be
continuing with the Select chess program
tomorrow hopefully at one point in the
future we will have our kids up to a
certain point where we can challenge
other clubs nationally internationally
whatever it may be and try to get some
collaboration from other organizations
so that'd be fun yeah I agree
you know one of the things that I've
I've had some conversations about I was
talking to the lady who runs the
Shanghai chess Association or Chess
Federation
chess club something and she said that
they always look for fun exhibition
matches that they can do sometimes
amongst the adult players but typically
you know the kids it's for for the
younger students and then so they'll
have something where you play in in your
home country the first year and then the
second year you come back and you play
in China and it kind of rotates like
that so you know we had talked about
doing something like that but
unfortunately like you said at the time
most of our students were now or just
beginner players or scholastic rated
kind of players and that the Chinese
kids are really good at a really young
age you know you'll have 18 1900 mm
rated kids
that's right yeah you're good correct
and that's that's really because when
you if you think about all the big good
clubs out there chess club's out out
there they're really known for producing
high level kids like Matt master levels
students and we are just taking
basically starting that process and
hopefully in a couple years we'll get
there I mean we already have a couple of
10 10 year olds that are basically -
around 1900 to 2000 so I think in a
couple years we'll get to that spot
really looking forward to it actually so
that's the goal Eric Rosen is dead we
feel old that's what I was exactly I was
saying I was like he must feel whatever
being culinary rose instead that's
alright I probably am old enough to be
Eric Roshan you are the Eric Rosen like
21 23 no resultant that he's probably at
least is he okay so I'm real I'm not
actually old enough to be but it's not
far off
all right one two three four five six
one two three four five so I'm up upon
we both have a pair of Bishops this is
like the kind of position I'll play all
day every day
I played the as a little kid I used to
play the perk defense where he played e6
in g6 and Bishop g7 Castle kingside and
then when I got a little older I started
playing some Sicilians mostly stuff like
dragons either a dragon or accelerated
or hyperaccelerated or something so when
you first learn the dragon did you learn
it because of the name it was called the
dragon because it sounded cool know a
lot of kids tell me that be like I
started learning this because this is
good because it's called dragon I was
like okay there's no no one right where
I'm a reason just got it sounded cool
kids right no sorry I'm calculating well
obviously you're gonna have to
Brooke okay a to their rookie Bishop c5
I'll be scared I'd be scared okay I mean
he's gonna take this pawn
not so lucky
all right well I guess we'll all defend
our poems I don't want to trade fake
bonds now so my opponents lower rated
that me and materials equal right now so
I'm gonna try to keep as much material
on the board as I can hopefully he'll
screw up or something
the only thing I really have going for
me I guess at this point is really
nothing probably no the only thing I
probably have going for me right now is
that it's kingside pawns and there's
eforp on they're all kind of isolated
that's the sounding boop boop boop
Master tomato I need a point I need one
more rating point Master tomato words on
14:47 you're give it to me better than
that
are you you using an engine Matt Master
tomato do we need a pilot engine as well
have an engine match I doubt they're
using in danger all right so Rick a5
Bishop b4 rookie 5 attacks a pawn but
that's about it
taking advice from Tony Chen now guys
now it's mistake number one right all
right so we're gonna defend this pawn a
whole bunch and then I'm gonna be able
to move my bishop somewhere don't say
that
Danny just said hold on
yeah the rook takes f6 cuz this is
pinned
oh wait a pen master tomato wait a pen
way depend uh Tony Chen tactics every
time you're your king you're getting
beat man
I know I won't have our rating over two
thousand I'm gonna have to just stay for
a draw I came out for jockeys you lose
points for that okay so what do you know
about Christian korilla Christian's a
grandmaster originally from Romania he
is he has recently been hired by the
University of Missouri he's their new
chess coach and so he's recruiting
players of all skill levels from around
the world really and getting them to
attend University of Missouri at
Columbia Columbia is like an hour and a
half away from st. Louis it's the
largest College in the in the state I
think something like 30,000 students go
to school they're known for its
journalism school is that reviewable the
largest mm-hmm I believe so is the
largest high school group up no I'll
just oh I think the largest largest okay
I'm gonna win this game luckily but not
because I deserve it
sorry master tomato I'm gonna flag you
but what what in life is really
deserving good
you're getting a flag master oh you
dropped a piece yeah
charge thank you for the game that was
fun we gained our one reading point T
Chen yes we're over 2,000 now we go to
gain zero what is that where where's our
1999 come on that's crap what all right
all right so we've got to play another
one going on Danya we are we out of time
all right let's do it one more one more
wait I want that 2000 one point one
point nineteen foot well you gotta play
guys in the 1941 thing that's right I'll
play well God and he laughs at me I said
I'm gonna play well and then I play this
opening so I'm from Romania to Batman
Begins we played earlier obviously we
had a Romanian guy to Bureau Gore esq I
think it's how you say his name he was
one of our resident GM's
great guy super super friendly I think
everybody liked him a lot so I think
we'll invite to Biru back at some point
to be a resident GM again one of our
viewers asked how did you train to get
so strong well for me it was you know I
started playing chess really before
chess books and all of that jazz I'm
sorry before computers so it was a lot
of chess books
do you do you think books do you think
chut stressed books are like a dying
thing now that like I don't know I think
people still really like the experience
maybe it's just that old nostalgic sense
of cracking the book and smelling you
know they have a certain scent about
them and sitting down over your board
it's of course it's much much easier to
to you know study with a computer where
you can click through variations and go
back to a position without remembering
exactly what it was well it looks like
our felt our resident teenager is on the
chat as well Nicholas risk Oh Nick risk
Oh shop buddy for all those who don't
remember who he is he is employee of the
st. Louis chess club he actually plays
the people a couple of times now he's he
has his own studio Sirius which I didn't
know to never watch it so Danny was just
saying he's the editor and he doesn't
remember what the name of it is anymore
you know I think it's because we have so
many gosh-darn lectures and shows and
things that we have load to YouTube you
know we're really lucky to have all of
the talented players in st. Louis that
we do
yeah so episode 2 right now is is in
processing this is one of those
positions where everybody's developed
all of their stuff you know efficiently
and now you got to find a plan all right
let me pull stock visually yeah there we
go stock fish
okay so I think I want his light squared
bishop but he might play Knight takes
ue4 let's see I'm just now starting to
look at this game so I have no idea
what's going on let me see here I just
heard a scoff from back the back room
how dare you scoff at me the audacity I
will lock Isaac's yell you yelling at me
for some reason I don't understand what
I did to him I don't know where my
pieces go just make a move
Romeo and Julia mathy I challenge you
guys again I had to go in now I'm back
welcome back this is probably our last
game so I don't know if we'll actually
get to you but join us tomorrow 3 p.m.
oh that's right so it'll be our resident
Grandmaster in residence that's gonna be
sorry that's gonna be playing the people
right now does Grandmaster Jessie cry if
you guys haven't met Jesse he's awesome
he's a really cool dude
I actually I actually talked to him
before we started the show he was going
on for a run and the really nice guy
really chill it's one of those like he's
one of those grandmasters that like it
or not
how should I say what's the good word of
saying it not like he's normal
yeah not not pompous not uh you know all
that stuff
he's down-to-earth he or a guy right one
of the things I like most about Jesse is
he has a very clear way of explaining
things you know he has a style that is I
don't know seems to drive with my my
desire how I learned yeah we're on that
night
Yeah right the night I'm going to I
think it's gonna go to c5 and then ecigs
hopefully uh-huh all right we got to
play fast now
yep
time
down on come on man you don't yeah play
fast I best do what deal
push that guy back I can't age three
hands
okay okay you gotta win on time yeah one
on time
haha it's okay it's okay
nobody freak out we're doing fine we're
still drawing hopefully
pre-move yeah pre move all the time oops
he has so much more time I don't get it
alright alright dang it game give you
hand good job good job again the game
alright everyone thanks a lot I had a
great time playing you you know
obviously it's much harder to do when
you're talking to people but don't
forget that we always play the people
here at the st. Louis chess club you can
challenge us
tune in watch our stream you know give a
shout of encouragement or heckle
whenever you play like I do so alright
join us tomorrow 3 p.m.
plague GM chassis cried place against
the people thanks to you then this has
been a presentation of the st. Louis
chess club